now the Avengers and the game is finally
out in theaters the directors Joe and
Anthony Russo have been able to freely
expand on some of the movie's plot
details one of these which came to light
a recent Q&A session for endgame has
even hinted that future Marvel movies
could be setting for a major comeback
according to slash film someone in
attendance at the Q&A asked to Russo's
to run through exactly what happened
with the Infinity stones at the start of
the movie the directors confirmed that
three weeks after his initial snap
fallows utilized the Infinity stones
once again but this time to destroy them
preventing them from being used to
reverse his work Thanos using the stones
to destroy themselves was one of the
major inciting incidents of endgame but
there's one little issue were there time
doesn't function correctly without them
more the heroes are snatching up the
Infinity stones in the past the ancient
one explains to Professor Hulk that you
can't just pluck a stone from a certain
place in time and not return it as that
would create a branch alternate timeline
overrun with disorder just not the kind
of disorder showing him back to the
future time travel the ancient one tells
hope that the Infinity stones are
essential to the flow of time and that
they must be replaced at the exact
moment in time from which they are taken
so if the stones are so important to
preserving a properly functioning
timeline why didn't the universe evolved
into complete chaos after Thanos
destroyed them well as the Russos
explained the nose didn't actually wipe
the Infinity stones out of existence he
just reduced them to atoms the Russos
indicated that this means the stones are
still out there floating around on an
atomic level though they may not be
tangible or fit for use in their current
state the Infinity stones remain a part
of the universe and will continue to
keep things in order
this would suggest that the Infinity
stones could appear again in a future
Marvel movie plenty of characters have
wielded the Infinity Gauntlet throughout
Marvel's history so there's a ton of
source material for writers and
filmmakers to use if they wish to bring
back the stones if anyone's going to be
the key to the Infinity stones return
there's a good chance is going to be
Adam warlock who has been tied to the
stones since that print debut but
sometime Adam was a primary bearer of
the Infinity stones and the Infinity
Gauntlet but what's more important aside
he has a pretty messy history with
Thanos and to service the Living
Tribunal a cosmic entity that preserves
equilibrium amongst all realities in the
Marvel Comics multiverse the kicker here
both Avengers and Game
this predecessor Avengers infinity war
were meant to include the Living
Tribunal and Adam himself was close to
being included in infinity war so kid
Marv will be saving Adam for phase four
of the MCU in the hope of folding him
into the franchise off the back of these
atomic Infinity stones it seems
plausible Marvel could even bring the
stones back and introduce Adam all in
one movie infinity warren endgame
screenwriters christopher markus and
stephen mcfeely have previously
mentioned that the character can't just
show up from nowhere and Marvel would
have to quote practically make an Adam
warlock movie to bring the character
into the universe but if it happened
that would be an ideal moment to revisit
the Infinity stones even if a solo movie
isn't in the cards for Adam however he's
likely to play a pivotal role in the MCU
moving forward and if the Infinity
stones never appear in the MCU again
which could be the case at least fans
won't lose any more sleep wondering just
what the heck happened to them check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]